good morning
and welcome to all those residents who
are watching via the council's live
stream
on friday the 9th of april 2021
we received the very sad news that his
royal highness of prince philip duke of
edinburgh
had passed away at the age of 99.
the funeral service is scheduled to take
place tomorrow saturday the 16th of
april at 3 pm
and will be preceded by our national
minute silence
members of rocha district council have
therefore gathered this morning in honor
of his royal highness the prince philip
duke of edinburgh
and i will shortly be inviting group
leaders or their representatives to say
a few words before we take part in rocha
district council's two minutes silence
prince philip's contribution to our
nation serving loyally
at the side of her majesty the queen for
more than 70 years
cannot be underestimated in addition
the young people in our district have
benefited significantly from
participating in the duke of edinburgh's
award scheme for a number of years
a scheme founded by him which has
enabled many young people to build the
skills
confidence and resilience they have
needed in order to make the most
of their lives our thoughts are with her
majesty the queen
i have written to the queen's private
secretary on behalf of rochford district
council
to express condolences to the queen
and all the royal family
we have seized apologies for today from
councillor mr hoy councillor mrs
christine mason
councillor newport and council wilkinson
councillor wootten can i please ask you
to say a few words
thank you chairman and i would like to
echo and very much support
the sentiments you have expressed
especially in respect of the devotion to
duty
and support to her majesty the queen
which his royal highness duke of
edinburgh gave over
many many years
after so many very eloquent tribute
speeches
which we have heard over the past few
days
as leader of rochford district council
there is absolutely nothing
i can sensibly add today to adequately
sum up honoring
the extraordinary life of the duke of
edinburgh
in a life where he achieved so much
whilst it is a privilege to be a
community representative
we as counselors know only too well
being in the public eye does not come
without challenge
and comment at times especially if
you're a bit of a character
with a sense of humor as undoubtedly the
duke of edinburgh was
his commitment and devotion to public
service
was simply amazing and beyond question
albeit that like us some of his comments
got him into trouble from time to time
the tribute which has most struck a
chord with me
is from his daughter princess anne
she said my father has been my teacher
my supporter and my critic but mostly
it is his life well-lived and service
freely given
that i most wanted to emulate
his ability to treat every person
as an individual in their own right with
their own
skills comes through all the
organizations
with which he was involved
in conclusion i believe we as
individuals could well heed
some of those values in the way in which
we lead our lives
and that we encourage people to
contribute to the charities
to enable the good work he started to
continue
that would be the finest practical
legacy and tribute
we could pay to his royal highness the
duke of edinburgh
sir you have served this country proudly
rest in peace thank you chairman
thank you council button i shall now
i shall now ask councillor adrian eaves
deputy leader of the rocha district
residence
to say a few words counselor eaves
thank you chairman there's been much
written and commented
on his royal highness prince philip duke
of edinburgh
since his passing a man known for his
straight talking and military past
a husband of 73 years which in itself is
to be applauded in this day and age
i want to concentrate on one
extraordinary element of
prince philip's life my mother who
passed away only a couple of months ago
was a staunch royalist
she was known to go to london for any
royal related events
trooping the colour the coronation
various commemorations and the like
she took great pride in telling us his
children how she slept on the street in
london on the occasion of the royal
wedding all those many years ago
just to make sure she had a good good
spot to view the proceedings
at all these events prince philip was by
the queen's side
he never upstaged the queen but it was
always there to support her
prince philip had a difficult childhood
and one that most would have found
challenging
particularly difficult must have been
over his mother with her struggles with
mental illness
in the prince's early years
it is often said these days that behind
every successful man is a strong woman
in the case of the queen and prince
philip it could be said that this was
the case but the other way around
in many ways that made prince philip an
early trailblazer
for men to be supporting women in
powerful positions these days
not unusual these days but much less so
when the queen and prince philip were
married
no one can deny the unfailing support
that he had given the queen
in all their many years together through
the good and bad
indeed the queen acknowledged it in her
announcement soon after he passed away
perhaps then we can learn from prince
philip's example in our own lives
putting others first is not a weakness
but an attribute to aspire to which
results in a higher attainment for all
those around us
for being that role model i suppose
salute the man
we all knew as his royal highness prince
philip
duke of edinburgh may he rest in peace
thank you councillor eves um counselor
newport leader of the liberal
democrat party is unable to be with us
today his words
will be spoken by angela hutchings
acting man
director of rochford district council
angela thank you chairman his royal
highness prince philip
was the embodiment of service in our
country for over 80 years
he was one of the last wartime heroes
and throughout the post-war period
he championed robust individualism a
trait that occasionally got him into
trouble
he had many important achievements one
very significant accomplishment which
bore his name and continued undiminished
to this day
is the duke of edinburgh awards scheme
for young people
one of the local liberal democrat family
daniel erlund was a recipient of the
duke of edinburgh award in his youth
his challenges were as varied as looking
after an old gentleman
sports training and a long trek over
several days
camping cooking and orienteering
the duke perceptively saw that these
sorts of challenges would build
confidence and self-esteem in young
people
stretching them in many ways and
equipping them for life and the many
challenges it would bring
what better memorial can a man have than
to provide a path to good citizenship
thank you chairman thank you angela
hutchings
there will now be two minutes silence
foreign thank you all members
officers and residents for attending
today
thank you